>> IT'S BEEN MORE THAN 60
MILLION EUROS SINCE THE
DINOSAURS ROLLED THE.
AROUND AFTER A CITY SIZED
ASTEROID WIPED OUT THREE
QUARTERS OF ALL LIVING SPECIES
ON OUR PLANET, BUT HOW EXACTLY
THIS DOOMED THE DINOSAURS
REMAINED UNCLEAR FOR A LONG
TIME.
SCIENTISTS PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT
THIS WAS DUE TO THE SUIT
PRODUCED FROM WHAT FAR, IS
TRIGGERING A GLOBAL WINTER.
BUT THERE IS A NEW STUDY OUT
THAT SUGGESTS THE FINE DUST
FROM THE PULVERIZED ASTEROID
MAY HAVE PLAYED A BIGGER ROLE
THAN PREVIOUSLY KNOWN.
BLOCKING OUT THE SUNLIGHT AND
SHUTTING DOWN LIFE NEARLY TWO
YEARS.
THAT CAUSED MASSIVE COLLAPSE IN
THE FOOD CHAIN, ULTIMATELY
LEADING TO A MASS EXTINCTION.
AND THE END OF THE TUNNEL
STORAGE.
JOHN IT MAY NOT TO DISCUSS THIS
IS ASTROPHYSICIST HOW CAME --
YOU ARE HERE TO REALLY SOLVE A
HUGE MYSTERY FOR ME AND SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE.
THIS IS A STUDY PUBLISHED IN
THE JOURNAL NATURE GEOSCIENCE.
AND IT SEEKS TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION.
WHY IS IT THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
THIS BEFORE.
AND YOU THINK IT'S POSSIBLE,
PERSONALLY?
>> IT'S PLAUSIBLE BECAUSE IT IS
BASED ON REAL DATA.
SO THE ACTUAL MATERIAL, IT'S
CRAZY, BUT IT'S SET THE 6
MILLION YEARS OLD BUT WE CAN
STILL GO AND CATHERINE.
AND SEE WHAT'S IN THERE.
THEY ACTUALLY FOUND THIS FINE
DUST AND THAT WAS THE
EXPERIMENT TOURS, BUT ON THE
COMPUTATIONAL SIDE, THEY HAD TO
ACTUALLY CREATE THESE MODELS
THAT SHOW NOT ONLY HOW THE DUST
INTERACT WITH SUNLIGHT, BECAUSE
IT ABSORB, IT DOESN'T REFLECT
IT, BUT ALSO HOW DOES THE DUST
AND DIRECT WITH THE ATMOSPHERE.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND IS THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF MATERIAL
COULD STAY AIRBORNE FOR 15
YEARS.
>> WOW.
AND PRODUCING, BASICALLY, A
CHAIN REACTION.
KILLING OF PLANT LIFE FIRST AND
THAT IS WHAT WOULD HAVE CAUSED
THE DINOSAURS TO BASICALLY GO
EXTINCT?
>> RIGHT.
SO WHEN YOU SHUT DOWN
PHOTOSYNTHESIS, BASICALLY,
SUNLIGHT AS IT MAKES IT TO THE
GROUND.
PLANS AREN'T ABLE TO MAKE THEIR
FOOD.
SO PLAN A TOURISTS HAVE NO
SOURCE OF THE FOOD TO EAT.
NOW WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT MEANS EVERYTHING THAT
EIGHT PLANTS IT'S GOING TO DIE.
AND EVERYTHING THAT EATS
ANIMALS IS GOING TO DIE.
SO WHAT REALLY DETERMINED WHAT
WAS GOING TO LIVE AND NOT LIVE
WITH HOW MUCH YOU NEED TO.
EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE, WHY DID THE
DAMAGE WAS DONE WITH THE
CROCODILE EONS OR ALLIGATORS,
THEY SURVIVED?
THE REASON IS BECAUSE DONALD
WERE WARM BLOODED LIKE US, AND
JUST LIKE WE NEED TO EAT THREE
MEALS A DAY TO, LIFT THOSE
VICTIMS WAS NEEDED A LOT OF
FOOD.
A CROCODILE TODAY, BECAUSE
THEIR CARBON, THEY DON'T USE
MUCH ENERGY.
THEY EAT ONCE A YEAR, THEY CAN
SURVIVE.
SO THE SMALL THINGS SURVIVE,
THE COLD BLOODED SMALL THINGS
SURVIVE.
BUT IF YOU ARE BRICK AND FOUR
BLUE, WHAT'S THE FOOD WEB SHUT
DOWN YOU HAD VERY --
YOUR DAYS WERE NUMBERED.
>> SO THE SCIENCE BEHIND THIS
RELIES ON A COMPUTER MODEL THAT
SIMULATED BLOCK THE ATMOSPHERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE AT THE
TIME.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN TAKE
AWAY FROM THAT, AS WE TRY TO
PROJECT FORWARD?
WE WERE TALKING A LOT ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW OUR
ACTIVITIES AS HUMANS AS A
FREETHINKER ATMOSPHERE.
WHAT CAN WE?
TAKEAWAY >> ONE THING TO NOTE,
OUR ATMOSPHERE IS A REALLY THIN
LAYER.
EVEN IN THE LIFETIMES OF MODERN
HUMANS, WITH HAD THREE BIG
ATMOSPHERIC EMERGENCIES.
WE HAVE HIT ACID RAIN, WE'VE
HAD THE HOLE IN THE OZONE LAYER,
AND NOW WE HAVE GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE WARMING OF THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE.
AND SO THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
TIME IT'S HAPPENED.
THAT EVENT DID.
IT SO OUTDOOR SPACE CAN DO IT
FOR IMPACTS.
GEOLOGY CAN DO IT THROUGH
VOLCANOES.
AND LIFE ALSO DOES IT.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
WHAT WE HAVE DONE SO FAR IS,
WE'VE JUST LIVED OUR LIVES.
THEN WE, GO OOPS, LOOK WHAT WE
DID, LET'S FIND A WAY TO SOLVE
IT.
WE COULD BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
MINDFUL AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
PARTICULATE MATTER DOES HAVE